well we we got to admit that Putin uh is
really the master of strategic surprises
especially uh when it comes to the
information space
um by his appearance first uh in Crimea
and now in mariopul he is trying to send
two important messages both to the West
as well so his domestic audiences to the
West the message is one of defiance you
know especially uh you know with this
visit coming uh on the wings of the ICC
decision ruling in the hey pretty much
he's showing that he's Unapologetic uh
and he you know effectively he wants to
show that he is
above those uh those legal developments
uh and also to his people he's showing
that he's in control
um ultimately uh you know as you saw
he's visiting different locations there
he wants to show the Russian people that
you know he's taking care of things that
he's personally involved this is part of
this uh information Warfare which is
really the centerpiece of Russian hybrid
Warfare but also of Putin's
personalistic uh grip on power I mean
the stability of his regime is the
center of gravity for Putin and
therefore he he knows how to play this
information game quite well and
information uh uh the Warfare requires
also escalation dominance also if the
West does something uh to try to
um put pressure on him he lashes out he
pushes against that with such
um messages which the search visits and
also of course he's saying uh he's
telling the world in Ukraine Crimea is
ours obviously the 18th of March was the
anniversary of the illegal annexation of
Crimea by Russia so many messages both
in his Unapologetic he's not yielding
obviously and he's still you know
capable of surprising both the domestic
and international audiences with
September
that effort to control the information
space as you say is is when the
President Putin is a master in but I do
wonder about the decision as well to
visit the particular areas that he has
including so the Children's Center in
Crimea and then a theater in Mario Paul
with a sort of symbolism that that will
have well that
well the idea that he's gone to a
children's center in Crimea the day
after he is accused of illegally
deporting children from Ukraine to
Russia well that that message won't be
lost on the Russian people will it no of
course yeah absolutely they will spin
the story as uh you know they always do
that put in uh actually loves children
but he takes care of children uh that
what what he and his commissioner for uh
for uh children's uh Affairs did was
actually uh you know benevolent
beneficial for those children Etc I mean
the Russian propaganda knows how to spin
those stories uh yeah you're right these
are well selected sites uh for the
purposes of Russia's uh this information
campaign and it's definitely tied to uh
this um ICC ruling this is part of of
the kremlin's narrative and and it's
it's so we we can we can say that the
information uh Warfare has begun the
information campaign to actually uh try
to exonerate put in at least in the eyes
of the Russian population and of those
Nations and audiences that support
Russia yeah and let's just look at a
couple of uh hours 24 hours or so mark
because there is still a plan in place
for president Xi Jinping to travel to
meet Putin I guess Putin will have to
travel back from marry your Poll for the
meeting in Moscow what difficulties is
that going to place on President XI and
the Chinese State who you know before
the War Began said they were standing
back to back with Russia but now
President Putin is an indicted war
criminal well you'll be um I would say a
serious reputational blow to
um present C uh obviously meeting with
someone who is now a pariah effectively
a criminal in the eyes of the Civilized
world and of course China still depends
on its commercial relations with the
West uh especially Western Europe where
the court is located but on the other
hand the sea is an ideological uh leader
and I suspect that in this case ideology
the ideological affiliations and the
alignments of of his interests with with
those of of Putin that is distracting
the west and keeping the West uh
um involved in a theater that's away
from Taiwan away from East Asia might
actually play uh better for Cedar for
um I mean I would be surprised if he
cancels the visit obviously there are
many many important things to decide
there the supply of Chinese ammunition
which has been being reported already by
by the U.S intelligence therefore
um the propaganda will find a way to
spin it both on the Chinese and the in
the Russian side and and uh you know
explain it away
yeah okay Mark I do appreciate your
analysis as well thank you very much